quand j'étais au collège un de mes profs
le cancer on nous disait qu'il lui
restait plus beaucoup de temps vivre
mais ça me semble absurde il était là il
faisait cours et tout avait l'air
d'aller bien sauf qu'un jour la nouvelle
est tombée il s'en est allé mais
pourquoi leur ton du cancer je veux dire
c'est juste une petite boule de cher non
ça n'arrête pas le coeur ça ne m'est pas
le cerveau dans le coma alors ça fait
quoi il vaudrait mieux que tu le saches
parce que toi là qui me regarde voilà
voir le cancer 39 25 % des gens seront
touchés par cette maladie à un moment ou
un autre de leur vie c'est même la
première cause de mortalité en france si
tu pensais partir tranquillement dans
ton sommeil seulement si tu as de la
chance contrairement à une idée reçue le
cancer n'est pas une maladie récente on
la retrouve en egypte des morts de
tumeurs 3000 ans avant jésus-christ
alors comment ça se fait qu'en cinq
qu'il en soit toujours aussi impuissant
un cancer ça fait quoi dans ton corps à
l'intérieur d'un humain ça grouille de
vie tu as 2 trillions de division
cellulaire par jour ça sert à réparer
des muscles ou nettoyer tellier cellules
sont tout ça tu serais juste en train de
pourrir pour se diviser les cellules
utilisent votre adn comme plan de
construction ce qui amène à beaucoup
d'erreurs mais genre vraiment beaucoup 1
120 milles pour une seule division
cellulaire c'est flippant parce que
comme vous le savez un cancer ça démarre
à cause d'une erreur et si votre corps
n'est pas constamment criblé de cancer
c'est qu'on a trois lignes de défense
d'abord les enzymes réparatrice daden
qui vont vérifier ce qui a été recopiées
ensuite la réparation est trop complexe
ont déclenché la pop cause la cellule
endommagé s'autodétruit grâce à sa 2000
cellule potentiellement cancérigènes
sont éliminés en vous toutes les
secondes malheureusement ça marche pas
toujours car pas de bol une mutation
peut avoir touché le gène p53 celui qui
s'occupe de l'autodestruction sur les
plus de 20000 gènes de notre adn il a
fallu que ça tombe sur lui on le
retrouve défectueux dans plus de la
moitié des cancers il reste quand même
une ligne de défense votre système
immunitaire il peut détecter les
cellules malades et en faire son quart
d'heure sauf que pas de bol pour vous ça
n'a pas marché une nouvelle mutations de
l'adn afférents de vos cellules
cancéreuses invisible normalement une
cellule saine produit une molécule
chimique pour dire est légal c'est bon
je suis gentil c'est la cytokine
la cellule cancéreuse l'a très bien
compris et donc un an produit plein le
loup est dans la bergerie
notre cellule cancéreuse n'a alors
besoin que d'une dernière mutation pour
atteindre sa forme finale le pouvoir de
se répliquer rapidement et à l'infini
c'est là qu'interviennent les ogm qui
vont brésil équilibre entre créations et
destructions de cellules ainsi que la
télomérase une enzyme normalement
endormi dans la cellule qui lui permet
de se réparer à l'infini vous l'aurez
compris avec toutes ces conditions avoir
un cancer est statistiquement très
improbable rendez vous compte du nombre
de pouvoirs génétique qu'une cellule
doit acquérir pour devenir le super
vilain régénération infinie des
activations de l'autodestruction et
camouflage la cytokine il ne lui manque
alors qu'une chose pour vous détruire
l'énergie le cancer a besoin de pirater
votre corps pour obtenir du sucre de
l'oxygène de quoi se développer pour ça
il va construire ses propres vaisseaux
sanguins pour détourner des nutriments
le cancer prend tout qu'importe si vos
cellules saines ont aussi besoin en fait
avoir une tumeur c'est comme porter un
bébé ce que vous mangez va directement
pour lui même si avec cette tête ça
n'ira jamais à l'école le cancer devient
terriblement dangereux quand il
s'approche de vos vaisseaux sanguins
principaux leur paroisse est normalement
solide mais les cancers sont capables de
les faire fondre grâce à des enzymes une
fois fait il a non seulement accès à de
la nourriture à volonté mais aussi à la
totalité de votre corps il suffit que
quelques cellules cancéreuses copier se
détache se laisse porter par le sens et
elles peuvent se déplacer n'importe où
pour faire grandir un nouveau cancer
ailleurs une nouvelle colonie une
métastase à ce stade vous êtes déjà
foutu le cancer pompe l'énergie ton
corps prend la place des organes vitaux
qui peuvent plus fonctionner et c'est
comme ça que tu fini par mourir
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que je fasse pour
éviter un cancer simple ne pas avoir de
malchance comme on vient de le voir pour
qu'une cellule deviennent cancer et il
faut toute une série de mutations
improbable mais avec un crayon de
mutations cellulaires chaque jour vous
imaginez bien qu'à un moment vous coché
tous les numéros du loto ça peut donc
arriver à n'importe qui à n'importe quel
âge mais plus on vieillit plus les
erreurs sont fréquentes dans l'adn est
moins nos lignes de défense sont fortes
votre vie vous devez donc travailler sur
ces deux points et on va vous lister ce
qui peut les perturber 1 les
rayonnements qu'ils soient du soleil ou
de la radioactivité le principe est à
peu près même une particule très
énergétique va traverser votre corps et
percuté un atome de votre adn le choc
est violent la structure moléculaire est
instable et tout peut se retrouver
modifié vraiment pas de bol car à
l'échelle subatomiques vous est
constitué à 99 99% de vide il faut donc
que la particule touche pile les bons
atom qui vont [ __ ] le dawa c'est pour
ça que des mamies ultra bronzer sur la
plage ou des liquidateurs de tchernobyl
peut s'en sortir indemne parce que leur
adn a esquivé la catastrophe de l'alcool
comme on passe de délicieux fruits qui
reposent quelques mois dans un tonneau à
une substance cancérigène le responsable
c'est l'éthanol qui se dégrade dans
votre corps en acétaldéhyde puis cros
total des ide qui adore se lier à l'adn
ce qui va donc créer des erreurs du coup
d'augmenter vos chances de développer un
cancer sur tout le trajet du tube
digestif jusqu'à la prostate 20% des
concerts ont pour cause l'alcool 3 la
cigarette pourquoi la cigarette tue vu
que c'est pas détaillées sur les paquets
on va vous expliquer dans une bouffée de
fumée il ya plus de 70 produits
chimiques différents et même du polonium
210 radioactifs à cause des engrais
utilisés qui se retrouvent dans la
plante alors je vous vois venir moi je
suis poussent la fumée de bio sans
pesticides maintenant relier une plante
à haute température ça produit forcément
des réactions chimiques dangereuses 25 %
des gens qui ont un cancer sont fumeurs
avec 17 % de chances de survie
4 l'amiante à une époque on en mettait
partout parce qu'en soi c'est pas une
molécule dangereuse c'est plutôt la
façon dont elles se regroupent en fibres
très fine des mini aiguille
microscopiques qui se baladent dans
l'air et que vous respirez elles vont
alors entrer dans vos poumons et ne plus
en ressortir ce qui va constamment
endommager votre organe l'inflammation
réparation et donc risque d'erreur 5 la
junk food ça j'ai jamais compris y'a pas
de poison là dedans contrairement à une
idée reçue le sucre ne donne pas le
cancer pas plus lui nourrit la tumeur
par contre une autre glycémie c'est
cancérigène et l'obésité ça l'est encore
plus
15 à 20% des cancers la science n'arrive
toujours pas à l'expliquer est ce que si
les macrophages présent dans gras qui
produisent des substances toxiques ou
est-ce que c'est l'excès de graisse qui
asphyxient vos cellules obligeant votre
corps allait renouveler plus souvent
même manger sainement ne vous sauf pas
toujours par exemple en thaïlande il ya
un plat réputé pour donner le cancer le
coït la juste du poisson cru mais il est
généralement affectés avec un ver
parasite qui se loge dans votre foi
comme l'amiante provoque une
inflammation constante 6 les maladies
comme le papillomavirus une ist qui une
des causes principales du cancer du col
de l'utérus
le principe reste le même inflammation
constante réparation erreur vous l'aurez
compris vous devez éviter à votre corps
l'exposition à un des particules
hautement énergétiques 2 les
inflammations du ray 3d substance
génotoxique qui abîment votre adn
pourquoi les traitements contre le
cancer ne marche pas à 100% si le cancer
colorectal ou celui de la peau ont des
taux de survie de presque 100 % il ya
des cancers qui vaut mieux ne pas avoir
par exemple celui du pancréas 5% taux de
survie ils cochent toutes les cases du
danger une proximité avec plein
d'organes risque de rechute détecter
souvent trop tard parce qu'invisible est
enfin très rapide c'est lui qui a tué
bertrand kamal l'ancien candidat de koh
lanta âgé de 30 ans seulement mais
surtout steve jobs le fondateur d'apple
on parle d'un dégâts les plus riches et
influents du monde et face au cancer
là rien pu faire on dirait pour qu'on
lui a pas juste enlever sa tumeur c'est
qu'une boule de chair après tout ouais
on peut le faire c'est même comme ça
qu'on soigne 70 % des malades mais vous
vous doutez bien plus la zone infectée
est grande plus la chirurgie sera
inscrit car on ne retire pas que la
tumeur au couple généralement un bon
centimètre de plus pour éviter qu'une
cellule cancéreuse se balade autour il
est même possible de retirer tous les
organes comme c'est le cas pour le
cancer du sein ou des testicules mais
que faire quand c'est pas possible on a
une deuxième solution la radiothérapie
on concentre un maximum de radiation sur
la tumeur bombardements rayons x ou aux
rayons gamma on parle de traitement
jusqu'à quatre vingts gré de radiation
absorbée huit fois la dose létale qui a
pu recevoir un liquidateur de tchernobyl
prenez pas peur c'est très localisés et
espacées dans le temps évidemment on
concentre pas un unique rayon puissant
vous ferai un trou au milieu du ventre
non l'astuce et avoir plein de vaisseau
de faible intensité qui convergent vers
la tumeur la technique la plus précise
et le couteau gamma avec 201 vaisseau
20% des rémissions le sont grâce à la
radiothérapie troisième solution la
chimiothérapie lorsque votre cancer est
à un stade 3 ans et où présent en
plusieurs endroits de votre corps il
faudra faire appel à la chimie pour
engager une guerre moléculaire le
fonctionnement est simple vu que les
cellules cancéreuses se multiplient
super vite il faut envoyer des produits
chimiques qui vise à arrêter leur
division il ya plein de méthodes collés
ensemble les deux brins l'adn imiter des
briques essentielles pour faire
dérailler la transcription ou paralyser
la cellule grâce à des alcaloïdes
végétaux vous l'aurez compris c'est du
poison cellulaire des sites aux toxines
qui impacte aussi les cellules saines
particulièrement celles qui se divisent
fréquemment les cellules des cheveux
celle du système digestif les testicules
les ovaires ou la production de globules
blancs c'est terrifiant mais ça reste
efficace cinq ans après le traitement 47
% des malades sous chimio sont encore en
vie contre 39% 104e solution c'est
qu'ils sont en cours et y en a beaucoup
hein par exemple des vaccins qui vont
entraîner ton système immunitaire à
reconnaître des cellules cancéreuses ou
mieux les crt chimérique antigènes
récepteur otis l immunothérapie s'est
littéralement des cellules terminator
modifiés génétiquement pour s'attaquer
aux antigènes du cancer entre cool vous
avez aussi le plomb-212 radioactifs
qu'on va faire s'attacher aux cellules
cancéreuses façon kamikazes et qui va
agir comme des nano bombe nucléaire
anticancer mais du coup si autant de
techniques existent pourquoi c'est si
dur de trouver ce traitement efficace
contre le cancer déjà il ya un gros
problème de diversité plus de 200 types
de cancer différents qui peuvent toucher
n'importe quelle zone du corps et vous
que la maladie tu lises ton adm tous les
cancers sont un peu différents un
traitement peut fonctionner sur un
patient mais pas sur l'autre pour ne pas
arranger les choses le concert va subir
deux constantes mutations génétiques qui
vont le faire évoluer au sein d'une même
tumeur une cellule cancéreuse peut être
différente de sa voisine un traitement
peut donc éliminer la première mais pas
la seconde qui va développer une
résistance c'est pour ça qu'on ne guérit
jamais du cancer une fois qu'on a le
tampon il ya toujours quelque chose
endormi en nous prêts à se réveiller à
n'importe quel moment
jusqu'au début des années 70 un cancer
s'était 80% de chances de mourir
aujourd'hui un cancer sur deux se soigne
en 2030 on prévoit trois cancers sur
quatre en attendant élites et les trucs
cancérigènes comme la cigarette l'alcool
le soleil ou la junk food pensez à vous
faire dépister au cidre on estime que 46
% des morts aurait pu être évité c'était
détecter plus tôt et surtout courage on
l'a dit en début de vidéo 40 % des gens
connaîtront cancer vous avez forcément
un proche touché j'espère pas vos
parents j'espère pas vous mais dans tous
les cas qui gardait espoir
la science avance et j'espère que
bientôt vos larmes et vos peurs ne
seront que de l'histoire ancienne
[Musique]